これじゃあ基世津翁で僕には分かりません
肇社長の動画面白い動画ランティ
僕今までものすごい活動はたしてきたんですよ
何本命チャンネルだけで約2200本ぐらい動画出せるわけですよ
見れません普通にも新規の方が肇社長で誰だろうと思って僕もとの見落としても前に
100歩をどうかあったらどれ見ていいかわかんねーんですよ
私もそうです僕自身も正直にどんな動画を撮ったらあの
うつらながら覚えてないです困ったこんなにたくさん動画を作ると思ってなかったんで
2200本の動画の例をもし皆さんに進めればいいかって言われると俺わかんないん
ですよまあもちろん再生回数が多い動画を見せるというわけですけども再生回数が多い
からって面白いわけじゃないんですよ
いやかねあの1億2000万開催フィットログミックっていう道徳と妻
んでつまんない動画でも再生されるのは youtube なんですなんですけど今回
は宅地に目を付けたいところはホース的に面白い動画はじめシャツを知らない人はじめ
車その他も見たことない人に勧められるようなをゴスロリ動画ってなんだろうと思って
今回調査してきましたはいどうやって調達するといいますと
もう普通の人とかなんとなく僕のどの見てる人だと31200
本の動画見てないんで2200本の動画を見ているかといえばそう
これはアンクライフの人たちだったら大抵の道がかなり含まれて見てくださっていると
思うんで本質的に面白い動画すっきーな動画って何ですかっていうのをアンケートを
聞いてポップランキング集を決められていただきましたありがとうございます呼吸
ろくに食べた本者の皆さん他の人が重されて思うものことを面白いと思ってるんでこの
ランキングこそ結構すべてた
思うんでまた初めてそのことが2200本見てねーなーとかちょっと見れねーなんて
思う人はランキングのたかまさんみるのもおすすめです
出会い買おう
さっそくみていきますお皿に私はまだ知りません第10位2018年8月3日公開接着
さえて家のものをくっつけまくった
笑笑はながらおーおめでとうございます
私が案件動画ですね案件動画でランクインするのすごいなぁ
うれしいです本当ありがとうございます案件動画のでちょっと動画つといけてないん
ですけども
誰から何かをくっついてやって取れなくてうーん
みたいなそういうのを繰り返してる動画ですなんだねしゃべり役所名だったんスかね
普段
動くものが動かないっていう衝撃で素敵な映像が撮れたのではないでしょうか
いや
個人的に面白かったと思います大ジョイおめでとうございます
次第9一方2019年12月23日崩壊早いた作ってみた
デフのためのプリテンダーオフィシャル冷え弾ディスプとっぺんだーネッツですね
ありがとうございます大注意でございますあの私はまで歌とか歌ったりしないんです
けどもうねとプリンティンがめっちゃくちゃ人気じゃないすか消え団の良いてで何が
ずっと脳内で替え歌を考えてて
そのプリテンダーと太ってんだって言うと全部に向けた歌を作ってみると思って作って
みたんですけどまぁこれで目新しい真新しいっていうので多分ランクインしたんだと
思いますか良いた作れないんで船
そういう意味のランティス多分これでございますツイ第8号
滅べきが2020年5月の18日公開ぴかぴーさんこれキャベツ6原理
ていますねこれを案件動画ですよとありがとうございますこれはそうですねあの自粛
期間に入ってたんでその人と会えないタイミングの撮影になったんですけどもう何が
できないかなと思っ
当時はてと呼べなかったセリーナを合成でここにおいて100人さんに応援されながら
キャベツと空してる動画なんですけどもこれはねあ
計算したね結構ヒカキンさんがしゃべる言葉に一家にぼかすに突っ込めるかっていうで
四角いなお1人でわけわかんない合成動画を撮ってくださったんでいい不明感が凄い
面白かったんだと思いますヒカキンさんありがとうござい
次がいない空ワーコレか
2017年8月発加工改革ホンギ裸の男30人でチンチン侍ゲームやってみた
うーん
ありがとうございます w 初期ん
おちんちんだから
7んだ前
行ったらどうぞ
一切ございません
[拍手]
面白いですちょっとおもしろかったですねそちんちんだからっていう当時流行ってた
変なゲームがあるんですけどそれを大人数の男でやってるっていう
パワーみせ下手漢字のおもしろたんですけどまぁ初めての日とかすると面白いかもしれ
ませんね se と思っ
ぜひこれ次ぎ第6 e ああああ懐かしい2014年7月15日公開バケツに
頑張りましたら助けてください第6位でしたおめでとうございます
1回見てに覚えてないんだ葉山得てれたらほんと出れない人バスだったんだ
ヤバイぞ
こんな伸ばしなりねーか
うん個人的にはまあまあですね何だろうでもサム2月良かったところある気がしますね
なんかに不思議なんすよね昔はおもしろいと思って倒すんですけど見返してみると案内
面白くないということ多いんですと見てみてくださいこれば穴にはまって出れなかった
だけの動画なんですけど結構本当に出れなくてその心の焦りというかそういうドキドキ
しながら観ちゃっちゅう君でちょっと面白いかどうかなのかも
知れませんただ僕たちと面白さがわかんなかったです次醍醐言えこれ
2019年12月18日公開オレオレオレを出れ0
俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺俺めでとうございます俺俺出るででおれオレを売られ0で終え溺れ
俺
でれるオレオレなるほどですねこっ
からトップ5なんですとコメントついてるの選んでいきたいと思いますとにかく2毒性
があると自分でも真似したいと思えたして何でもあったまぁに残る場所も子供もお腹を
抱えて笑うくらい大好きで子供に関しては俺を食べる時に観光
にする方ですはそんなありがとうございますこういうのいいですねこれアーマー再生さ
れてないに沿ったしか
ん
これは面白かったですね自分でもなんですけどあのオレオって音レッドここでできてて
それはここに組み合わせてんだかいろんなオーレを作るっていうところなんですけど
範囲なんて思ったほど再生されてるんですけどこういうのがランク入りするのがこの本
帳に遅いどんなランキングです次
第4 a オレ2017年2月の7日公開ワイン
全部混ぜて飲もうとスター倒れてしまったんんおめでとうございます
お酒ワイン所北2009年モデルなら結構昔からみんな作ってたんだね
えっ
ありがとう3コメントですとにかくよっていい形詰さんが面白席で可愛くて頭遠い一君
のワイン飲んで酔ってる中ワインの紹介も雪が彼は移籍でも何十回も見ましたこの時
ビザれがすごく好き
いまなによりどんどんよって一さんがとても可愛くて何回見ても方はたしますああああ
僕は可愛いけど動画ですねビジューがいいと言われるとこの時伸びずちょっと参考にし
たぞ
[音楽]
あこれはをロイは vine 飲むとすごい音がロボットしちゃうんですよね動きは彼
の良い形でめちゃくちゃだったそういう内容でしたねこれはちょっと本当になるほどと
思いますありがとうございます次
第3ここからは本当にもするんですよねこれ
2017年10月17日公開もやし男がマックナゲット宣告カッコ予定
第3位です
おめでとうございますます mac の人私好きじゃね
ソースなんかで100個付き所得マックナゲット100個砕けて参加
なんでコメントを読ませていただきます一さんとたナッツの今を変わらない空気感と
なんともいえないものの里
やはりそうなるよね感が好きです時を超えたナゲッツ親子とな月号とか管ないとから
つぶった飾り扇の中で一番つらそうだった品々ハサミが可愛すぎたからまあゲット今
自著みます
[音楽]
なるほどねこれは年200個を食べてみたっていう動画だしたいところをぜひ見て
ほしい
尾根てお肌魅せてしっかりと苦しみながらを食べるっていう一般的な人間の ob 動画
のイーベイだった気がしますねなんか普通にいま見返す3ではラケルところが多かった
んだ妄想か次
台にこれでねしました2019年3月の13日投稿
全員恥じる社長でた
別の日に撮ってみたら位にでございますありがとうございます
1年に1本はその代表作みたいなつがなんとなくてるんですけども2019に去年の前
にこれでしたねこの動画のおかげで本場で頑張ろうと思って無事第一志望校に合格でき
たらしいですおめでとうございましたがタリアータしてにへリーグって人がいると見る
たびに発見がある動画そんなに行くと思ってなかったですねああいうが
たぐらいにパッと思いついてです何か良い急いで撮ろうと取ってパーッとちょっとどう
です
何がばそれかわかんねー次
ハイアール第一でございます
たく想像できないんですね何だろう恋ダンスとかなでもありそうなおもろくないんだよ
な
出てる人はすごい豪華なんでこういうラーソンの可能性はあります
分かりません
流行る第1
こちらです
[音楽]
しずかったー2018年4月の12インチ今回
黒バーを真似しながら激動するウサギさんを大量に設置うバラバラバラバラ笑1位です
おめでとうございます
こんにちは
[音楽]
ああああああ
[拍手]
これ
うーんと1回見返してみるわ
あ
なるほどねーこれが俺のが率は遅いよねー
服雑屋会だってももっと頑張っ度がありましたよ24時間かけたらいいなら2週間かけ
ちゃった動画とかめっちゃお金かけて使ったところがたくさんある中で一番面白かった
動画がウサギの人形炭鉱が並べて一緒におしゃべりするんだけど動画
[音楽]
ここははいというわけで今回のランキング今ない感じになっております再生回数できれ
ば低いものが何食いしてますねこれ本当ファンのみなさんのおかげでって言うんですね
埋もれたお風呂移動がもあると思うんですけどもぜひこういう動画も見てみてはいかが
でしょうか
山ほど2000本あるとね分かんないしどれも何が面白いか何がつまらないからまあ
できればその
面白いとか何か発見になるとか
撮りたいと思ってるんですけどもすべてが遅いってわけにもいかないんだよ年に123
本ぐらいはなんかめちゃくちゃ面白いっていうのが取れればすべていいかなと思って
おります一応どの動画にも心を込めて作っておりますのでまだ見たことないとこがある
方はぜひ見てみていかがいいかがでしょ
はいことじゃまぁ半分頑張って行きたいと思いますじゃあ
あっハール helpers
[音楽]